[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him oh
Kev you're such a
cuck Kevin McCarthy does not have the
votes for impeachment it is clear from
his statement this morning I know I know
it probably feels feels like Kevin
McCarthy has the votes you're like no he
in and he announced an impeachment
inquiry no he didn't actually do
that what he actually did was he's
directing uh Trump's foot soldiers which
this is all at the direction of the
Cheeto dust q and honor Grandpa poopy
pants himself this is all in need for a
distraction I mean even Charlie Kirk is
tweeting it as we speak that this isn't
owed impeaching Joe Biden this is about
shutting down the government literally
that's what he's that's what Charlie
Kirk is saying they they want to shut
down the government they don't they
don't know how to govern so why would
you keep something open that you don't
know how to do that'd be really [__]
dumb and they're dumb as dog [__] so it
makes sense but they're not going to
impeach Joe Biden they're not I doubt
this even gets to the floor of the house
and the reason why the reason why that
Kevin what Kevin McCarthy won't tell you
is there are plenty of house Republicans
that represent and represent
constituencies of Biden districts
folks where Biden W those members can't
take that vote on impeachment because
they want to hold on to their own
power it's the whole point of their
power in the first place I mean that's
what Kevin McCarthy's
doing he's genuflecting to Trump here uh
through his allies in the house marjerie
Taylor green Matt gats Jim comr and Jim
I don't report sex crimes
Jordan it's what they're doing that's
what he's
doing but he's
directing he's directing the two people
that have had all the Time in the World
to figure out if Joe Biden can be
impeached or not and gather up the
evidence for impeachment and they
haven't done that Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan and James qanon
comr and they still don't have the
evidence we see it time and time again
every time they do an interview someone
ask them do you have the evidence
they're like well I I hope so I hope we
find
it I mean it would be great if we found
the evidence I mean even even the
talking heads in the Republican Party
are going on all the trader TV News
Network
saying we don't have the evidence that's
why we need the impeachment inquiry to
get the evidence that we don't have that
doesn't
exist and again this is just furtherance
of the [__] of the
lies they cannot operate without lies
folks they're in big trouble without
lies they need
lies they have to have
lies they're incapable of governing
we're going to see that at the end of
the
month again Charlie
Kirk head of turning points USA is
tweeting
tweeting as Kevin McCarthy was giving
his stupid little [__] speech about
how he's not going to impeach Joe Biden
he's just going to pretend to impeach
Joe Biden that's literally what they're
doing is
pretending it's all [__] it's all
fraud they have no not one single
shred abil of ability to govern
they can't keep the government open
they're not going to they can't they
don't have the votes they can't impeach
Joe Biden they don't have the
votes Kevin McCarthy is not the speaker
of the house he is Trump's impeachment
puppet everything that will be coming in
the in the months to come is to distract
to get to Iowa caucuses so that Trump
can win it's all distraction folks
I'm I'm telling you right now here's my
prediction you can put this on the
Discord and the doubt me
channel I think it's already in there
actually they're going to shut down the
government and they're going to say it's
government lockdowns damn you Joe Biden
they're L literally that that is going
to be what they're saying they're
goingon to go on every Trader TV News
Network they're going to go on every
mainstream Network and you know what the
mainstream media is going to do they're
going to say oh well that's not
completely
true that's what you don't you don't
think that that what BL but but no
that's not what the mainstream media
needs to do they can say that's a
[__]
lie it's a lie you the House Republicans
shut down the
government and by the way the country's
going to know this the country's going
to know what's actually happening it's
the Sheep they're trying to fool folks
it's the [__] sheep don't you see it
they're not trying to [__] with people
like us they're not trying to confuse
people like
us they can't afford for their flock to
walk away from them they can't afford
it they have to have the delusional it's
what a cult operates off
of I was listening to um MSNBC this
morning and there was two authors oh um
great authors about how democracies die
and they made a lot of good points but
there was one point um and I forget who
said it in the interview I I really do
think that there's producers listening
to the show which you should be you
should [__] listen and you should
take the words I say and post them and
plaster them everywhere on the
mainstream media until the mainstream
media starts talking like I talk we're
gonna have problems in our [__]
democracy that's for goddamn
sure but this morning they were like
like oh the Republican party is it a
cult they're like no no Republican no
they're not a cult I think I think
Willie gist asked the author that willly
guys obviously there's something you're
listening to that is saying that the
Republican party has been a cult for a
long time I wonder who's been saying
that and he asked the question to the
author is a Republican party of cult and
they said no and they are wrong they are
dead wrong the Republican party is a a
cult it has been for
decades it flew underneath the radar you
know they thin veiled their fascism as
conservatism for so long oh they did a
great bang up job of it to act like they
were conservatives pretending as if they
was conservatives they're not [__]
conservative get the [__] out of here
they don't even know what the word means
hell most of them don't even know what
the word democracy and Republic and
Constitution and Liberty means or
liberal for that matter what the [__]
would make you think they they know
anything about the the definition of
conservatism but this morning Kevin
McCarthy is putting on a show for one
[__] one Donald Trump to fool
his
flock that's all it is is to fool the
flock they're not trying to fool the
country they're trying to fool the
flock and it's working oh it's working I
guarantee you any [__] Mite out there
any dumb [__] that you run
into who thinks Joe Biden is a criminal
because Fox News and the Facebook told
me
so any of those people that oh they're
going Joe Biden is as good as gone he's
imp Peach now that's what they're going
to be telling
you best part is is that the Republican
Party The House Republicans are going to
fail at this the same way that they
promis people gas prices would tank down
to a dollar a gallon yeah you just vote
our dumb asses in in the House of
Representatives we'll get your gas to a
dollar a gallon when did that happen huh
I thought they were going to fix gas
prices remember that in 2022 remember
that and they were going to save gas
stoves from being extinct well aren't
gas stoves and ceiling fans extinct just
like Bud Lights gay Jesus [__] Christ
these people remember the other thing
they were going to do remember that they
were going to make sure Hunter Biden's
laptop was for the world to see in a man
they were going to make sure Hunter
Biden goes to jail for bribes and drug
use and
prostitution remember when they were
[__] freaking out that Weiss
Weiss was some kind of deep Stater now
it looks like Weiss the United States
Attorney in Delaware may may actually
indict Hunter Biden again on additional
charges after Hunter Biden told him to
go [__] himself after he riged on his
deal
wice this is all
Insanity every single bit of it is
insanity and the larger the insanity
Stacks up on top of each other the more
you're supposed to get
discouraged and the more you get
discouraged the more disengaged you
become cuz what they're counting on
folks here's what they're counting on
here's what Kevin McCarthy and the
Republicans want this is their desire
and they're talking about this [__]
behind closed doors you can [__] Bet
On It they're saying this if we can just
keep the Trump flock together if we can
just keep the voting block our
delusional cult together by
2024 and we can discourage enough people
who are the pro-democracy Coalition we
can win and American democracy is over
and we can take
power they're having those [__]
conversations behind closed
doors doubt me do it do
it don't disengage do not get
discouraged get encouraged by this folks
they are literally going to shut down
the government and try to convince the
American people that Joe Biden shut the
government down and is on Co lockdowns
that is literally what they're going to
say look I live in rule Missouri and I
go out in public and there aren't there
ain't nobody wearing masks nobody there
aren't no [__] lockdowns no one's
shutting down [__] in Trump country
where these people are believing this
garbage they're not shutting anything
down folks the only thing that they see
on the TV oh man the tube told me oh the
Shiny Bright Light told me this that
that there's lockdowns
don't give in to their [__] keep
calling them on it and let them step on
the [__]
rake they're gonna shut down the
government there ain't a goddamn thing
you or I can do about it we did we could
have done something about it the people
who voted these feckless [__]
into Congress could have done something
about it vote for someone who's not
feckless who wants to govern who's in
interested in representing their
constituents not Donald Trump because
let's face it the House Republicans are
only representing one constituent only
one Donald Jessica Trump that [__]
pile of goddamn [__] down at Mar Lago or
Bedminster wherever that Fu feckless
[__] is
today that's their constituency is
one
one they are the Army flock of
trump and they're doing everything in
their power to keep the lies together
and this morning they're pretending to
impeach Joe Biden which is hilarious oh
my God Kevin mccarth and and I know a
lot of people are gonna be like well he
said well Tony he said he said he ain't
got the [__] votes I've been telling
you for weeks he ain't got the votes
they would have done it before they went
to recess if he had those goddamn votes
he does not have the votes to impeach he
does not have the votes to keep the
government open he doesn't have it hell
they can't even pass military spending
for crying out loud don't even get me
started on the [__]
Senate with Tommy
tuberville but Kevin McCarthy is not the
speaker of the house he just wears the
[__] name tag that's it period and
Kevin I I have to tell you
I have to tell you you're doing you're
doing a bang-up job for the history
books to tell about this time period in
history you really are oh my God ma
manga is doing such a great job for us
to look back in history and know how
[__]
ridiculous that this time is how
ridiculous and how fascist the
Republican Party truly
is again a lot of people expected me
probably to come on here this morning
and defend the president United States
he doesn't need
defending he does not need
defending it is not something that I
have to sit here and Yammer on about
about well this this thing isn't true
and this thing isn't true and oh what
get the [__] out of here Joe Biden is
doing his [__] job yesterday they
were freaking out that Joe Biden is
doing his goddamn job as a world leader
and he wasn't at some ceremony for
September
11th which by the way they all [__]
they all [__] hate September 11th oh
they posted on social media everywhere
Lauren bobert marjor Taylor green Kevin
McCarthy all of them every [__] last
Senator every last congressperson who
voted
against who voted against the workers
and the volunteers and the F the heroes
that cleaned up 911 for their health
care they voted against that [__] and
they put up never forget what never for
forget you hate [__] people who
helped at 9/11 you hate [__] real
Patriots that's what we're supposed to
not forget you [__] feckless
[__] the same the same sons of
[__] are mad that Joe Biden's doing
his
job as a world
leader and well you know what to really
matter about he's not doing too bad of a
job because Vladimir Putin is meeting
with Kim Jung this
morning can you imagine can you imagine
the war that you started going so badly
that you have to go beg North Korea for
[__]
weapons oh vlat D and I cannot even
believe that the Republican Party thinks
somehow Vladimir Putin is the [__]
signal of strength in the world get the
[__] out of here with that nonsense this
guy's this guy's such a [__] B he can't
even put his own War together he's got
to go to the [__] murderous dictator
Kim jung-un of North Korea to get
weapons because he's so
desperate because China wouldn't even
help the [__] China's like no
that's I'm okay that's cool everything's
you know what you're I'm not we're gonna
stay out of that
one every turn that you take with the
Republican party in this country every
[__] turn you take
there's a
rake every day every hour every single
lie that they tell is another rake that
they're going to step on tomorrow and
next week and next month and next
year so you you as much as you should be
vigilant against fascism in this country
and you should engage in your democracy
as part of the pro-democracy Coalition
which I know you are a few of you aren't
you know you got the hate Watchers
aren't there they love to [__] hate
me so there's a bunch of fascists
watching you know in the
wings but as you're watching as you're
listening let me tell
you it is exciting to watch the
Republican party to throw out rakes that
they are going to step
on they are going to eat more rake
handle in the next year than they have
in the last six months and let me tell
you they've got their feeling filling of
[__] rake Handles in the last six
months
I mean whatever happened whatever
happened to their inquiry about Hunter
Bon's Coxs his picks of his dick
whatever happened to that huh what ever
happened to that what was it weren't
they gonna do something about
that weren't they gonna do something
about the weaponization of government
weren't they going to do something I
don't know what did they do besides a
lot of [__] talk in the house had
they done anything for the American
people in the last six months besides
talk about Hunter Biden's dick
huh have they done anything for you hell
they could barely get the debt ceiling
raised it took Democrats and Joe Biden
to do that [__] to trick Kevin McCarthy
and the Democrats and Joe Biden tricked
Kevin
McCarthy into raising the debt ceiling
he got his ass handed to
him and now his repayment he's gonna
pretend to impeach Joe Biden good [__]
them as a thank you as a thank you to
Democrats who saved this country's
[__] economy from Republicans
crashing it intentionally by not raising
the stupid ass debt ceiling which
shouldn't even be a [__] thing but
we're not even gonna have that debate
right
now as a thank you you're G to shut down
the government and then I'm telling you
what they're going to do is they're
going to shut down the [__]
government and they're going to say
government Co lock lock Downs oh Biden's
shutting down the country because of
coid that's what they're going to tell
you on Trader TV news networks I'm I
guaren godamn tee
it [__] write it down hide and
watch every last one of them are going
to be on some Trader TV News Network
saying yeah well Joe Biden's locking
down the government because of Co all
the all the federal Parks all the
federal buildings all that stuff is
because Joe Biden Co and Anthony fouchy
and all that Anthony fouchy he's a hell
of a demon he is not knowing that
Anthony fouchy isn't even in the
government
anymore they don't give a
[__] again it's all about it's all about
keeping their flock together they're not
lying to us we have brain cells to rub
together okay we know they're [__]
lies when they're
lies it's about keeping their flock
together it's about one constituent
Donald Trump and getting to the Iowa
caucus that's the most important thing
in this moment for the Republican
cult is get Trump to the Iowa
caucus they don't give a [__] about his
criminal ways [__] if they gave a [__]
about that they'd have abandoned him a
long time ago frankly they like that
feature of Grandpa poopy pants that's
their favorite part about that some
[__] is his criminal [__] ways he's
a fraud they [__] love that oh God
they there's nothing better they like
than a total [__] fraud trust
me but that's their goal that's what
they're going to do that's the entire
the entirety of the Republican party is
to just get the flock through to the
next event the next goalpost oh man oh
my God
it's the vaccine remember that [__] the
mask oh we got past that gas prices got
past that Bud Lights gay we got past
that they're going to get rid of gas
stoes we got past that oh they're gonna
ban ceiling fans we got past that Ted
Cruz they're only going to let us drink
two beers a week we got past
that it's always to get the walk to the
next goddamn
lie every
time now there is a disease in this
country and that is the problem there is
a disease in this country and Trump is
not the cause of the disease he's a
[__] symptom of that disease the
Republican party is a symptom of that
disease and we've had this disease for a
long
time this gaslit [__] that that
12 13% of our country suffers from at
any given
moment will we get through it absolutely
100% will we get through the Trump
trials absolutely 100% will we get
through the government shutdown
absolutely 100% we will keep marching
forward will it be tough H Sometimes
some days it'll be a
[__] but you cannot get discouraged you
cannot disengage you have to lean into
your
democracy and you have to do what
democracies do best stand on the
foundation of
liberalism that is what you must do you
must not waver in that fact because the
the battle that we are going to fight is
going to be at The Ballot
Box everyone harped on me about
the stepping on your dreams of the 14th
Amendment and that's what it is it's a
[__] fantasy about the 14th Amendment
it truly is it's a [__] fantasy but
you know what maybe it's not so much of
a fantasy if you really think about it
if you really think about today in the
context of what what is the to bring in
the
next year 18 months because it's not
going to stop after the election if you
think that they're not going to try to
steal this election or try to deny this
election you're out of your mind but the
next 12 18 months think about it in the
context of that right we the people
because we are the government it is us
we make up the Republic this democracy
that is that we have had since the
founding with the
Constitution the a living document that
progresses through time through history
and hopefully it will continue think
about it in the context of the next 18
months think about the opportunity that
we have in this country and in the world
really in the context of the 14th
Amendment
now I know he's going to be on the
ballots you're not going to stop him no
Secretary of State's going to do that
[__] I don't care what anyone says or
any legal scholar says or any legal
analyst I don't give a [__] there is no
Secretary of State that's going to do
what they say that that you want to have
done because it feels good but in the
context of the 14th Amendment don't we
have the ability to 14th his
ass don't we the people have the ability
to 14th him I mean I keep saying he
we're his jury cuz definitely are his
[__] jury in this country especially
if he becomes a nominee which he will
be but we have the ability to 14th his
ass again and again and again and
again as many times as we need to we can
stuff that son of a [__] in the
trash now maybe maybe his losses will
fill the trash bin of History but what
better for their legacy than absolute
loss at the hands of the
people at the hands of our
Liberty showing the world that trumpism
is not popular in this [__] country
again I've told you before over and over
that that truly is the big lie the big
lie isn't that he [__] lost or he won
or some whatever the f he
says the big line is that PE there's a
large majority of people in this country
that support him the [__] out of here
they hate his
guts even people who go out there and
they're like well I mean I I I wouldn't
vote for joeb so I gotta vote for Trump
trump they hate that son of a [__]
they're tired of him they're sick of
talking about him they're sick of us
talking about him they are sick and
tired of us [__] talking and mocking
Trump they [__] hate
it they [__] hate it and we should
continue to keep this country hating
that son of a
[__] that should be our main goal every
goddamn day and it is mine every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific right here
on YouTube Twitter and twitch make sure
to go to the Tony michaels.com that's
the tony.com follow us everywhere you
can buy me a shot there on the Tony
michaels.com too let me let me show you
the Tony michs really quick before we go
to a break we got some great guests
today go subscribe at the top of the
Tony michaels.com you'll catch every
single day you'll catch the newest
episode at the very top on that link you
can buy me a jagger shot right there you
know I like Jagger Meister most people
don't but I do and thank you for all the
shots that everyone has bought and also
if you want to get on screen with your
chat today just go to the venmo Super
Chat right there as well on neony
michaels.com I'll pull your comment up
we got some great guests so if you got
questions for those guests get them in
the vinmo super chat now we've got Greg
oer the author and the host of prevail
with Greg ol the podcast I was on what
we recorded the podcast on Sunday I
think it airs on Friday I believe is
when it's gonna air he's gonna be up
right after the break and then of course
we're gonna have Texas Paul today so get
your questions in the vinmo shot thank
you for everyone for joining today
today's going to be exciting time don't
forget right after the show Gabe
Sanchez's brand new show what was that
live airs right after this show it's
going to throw right into it you're not
even have to leave any anywhere if
you're on Youtube it'll go directly into
it and Gabe Sanchez surely will join us
just a little bit at the end of the show
here before we throw to him for his very
first show what was that line don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy P's mail
do you feel exposed to a government that
doesn't share your patriotic values if
any of these describe you then you're in
luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to my
new product paron blanket I've got you
covered paron blanket specifically Works
to make you feel safe and cozy after
your involvement on January 6th and if
you're one of the other m members of
Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're 100% made in
the USA don't delay and get your pardon
blanket today for just
$99.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking around did you know the paron
blank is real now those are real you can
actually get your very own pardon
blanket if you are anyone you know is at
January 6 if needs a pardon uh just go
to IAB sanchez. comom that's IAB
sanchez. comom you'll find the merch
score there don't forget to hang around
after the show very exciting today there
is going to be a brand new show right
after the Tony Michaels podcast it is
going to be what was that live with Gabe
Sanchez as it will be every Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday after this show
I'm super excited that Gabe has started
his new hour three days a week on
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday directly
after this show again if you're on
Twitch or you're on the YouTube channel
it will get directed straight to his
show you will not no need to go anywhere
you'll go directly to his show um I
can't wait to see what gabes has in
stores for us he's going to join us
later on the hour but right now I have a
special guest now with us Greg Oar the
author and the host of prevail he also
has another show he'll tell us about
these things he'll do it better than I
will you know how I am with
interjections H Greg my friend how are
you hey thanks for uh having me today
yeah no problem no problem um so I know
we had fun on Sunday we recorded for
your podcast but tell the audience tell
the audience about your show and the
other show that you have and about what
you do out there for democracy and then
we'll get into the issue with Kevin
McCarthy and the Traders over at the
excuse me the members of the House
excuse me um yeah I have a substack
which is called Prevail that's at Greg
O.S substack do.com um I also have a
podcast which is sort of an offshoot of
that that's available did I say your
name wrong oh my God no it's my fault
because you know you were on my podcast
so there's no I don't need to tell you
how to pronounce my name on my podcast
and then I realized as you were talking
I'm like oh [__] I forgot to tell them
because everyone you know you know you
know what's funny you know what's funny
is um so a while back before you get
into plugging your stuff there is I had
a troll farm that attacked me attacked
me and they're like Tony Michaels isn't
your real name I'm like yeah but see if
I use my real name no one would be able
to say it so it's a pseudonym that I had
but it is my name it's just a different
arrangement of my name so it's so funny
but I just I I I I get names wrong a lot
I get him wrong a lot sometimes it's
unintentional sometimes with Matt gats
it is totally intentional because yes
it's Matt K so I apologize for that go
on tell us tell us about your substack
and your and your your podcast totally
my fault my podcast is called Prevail
with Greg Oar it's available wherever
you get your podcast so just uh you know
you can go click the little plus button
or whatever and uh subscribe to that on
this Friday this very Friday it's a home
and home Tony because uh you're coming
on my podcast and we have a great we had
a great conversation um you made some
really interesting points about the role
of the media and what you're doing here
in this space
um you know uh being the rush Limba of
the left which is something that I had
not considered but I I think is urgently
needed and you're filling the Gap here
it's uh you're doing great work um the
other thing that I have is the 58 which
is uh the live YouTube show I have my my
shirt here yeah which I do with my
friend Stephanie cof who's Lincoln's
Bible on Twitter that's on Friday nights
live at eight o'clock so uh you know
it's a hang we hang and we talk about
stuff for an hour hour and a half and we
have a lot of nice fun guests on there
that teaches stuff so uh any one of
those places it's a live it's a live
show it's a live show right it's a live
show well there's nothing better than I
like than live shows you you can um you
can bet on that and all the links are
down below um for Greg there for the
substack um his podcast and also his
show with lb I think is the is the
moniker that they she has it's Lincoln's
Bible but they call her lb right yeah we
call her lb we call her I call her lb
because her name is Stephanie and my and
also my wife's name is Stephanie so
easier to
okay I got you I've I've occasionally
accidentally emailed uh lb like notes
from the school about my kids oh I see
thinking that it was the wrong
yeah problem that that mixup can can be
easy sometimes can be now Gabe this is
this is the premiere of of Gabe's show
so Gabe normally uh co-hosts with me
here on the show now he's GNA continue
to co-host on Mondays and then we do a
little segment on Friday it's called
bonehead of the week which is our
favorite segment just because we get to
mock them called them boneheads and we
have special music and graphics for him
so it's a great time um but Gabe is this
is his very first day of of having his
very own hour what was that live now he
doesn't what was that that's highly
produced um but today he's doing he get
there's so many stories Greg there's
like I know [__] mountains of
[__] that you got to sift through
here so every time he does a what was
that there's four other stories that
don't get attention so he decided that
he needed to do a live show to really
bring attention to some of these other
stories cuz I can't even get to them all
the audience is has been asking us to do
three hours for a long time so this is
the best solution we have is I do two
hours Gabe does an hour and everyone
gets everyone gets three hours of trying
to trying to muck through the the
[__] here speaking of [__] now
Kevin McCarthy is pretending to impeach
Joe Biden this morning his statement um
and I can pull it up here I I'll
definitely give us a clip but tell me
did you did you listen to his feckless
little statement that he gave this
morning I tend not to listen to him
because um my ears are very sensitive I
don't like hising little voice uh I read
about it and uh you know let your rant
was was fantastic by the way that which
I watched before I came on but uh let's
remember who Kevin McCarthy is you know
he he's he's a guy that uh after the
Insurrection happened within like I
don't know six weeks of the Insurrection
was down in maral Lago uh in front of
that Russian oligarch style door and
kissing Trump's ring you know that's who
he is he kissing his ring did you say I
think he was kissing more than that but
you know yeah but I mean in the mafia
sense of the work right and yeah so he's
he doesn't have any agency I guess like
he's he's in now he's in with Trump and
he's these guys are all in with Trump
until they you know until the the train
runs off the tracks however it runs off
the tracks um Trump isn't isn't it the
only choice that they have really though
I mean and why I've been saying since
December that Trump's going to be the
nominee like I I see no path forward for
anyone and the reason why is because he
has such a strangle hold um because
everyone's like oh The Establishment and
there's a uni party [__] even Mitch
McConnell can't seem to fend off Trump
well he can't even seem to fend off a
glitch but yeah even the Senate
Republicans which I know you know a
thing or two about Senate Republicans
they can't even fend off Trum [__] they
can't even get rid of Tommy tuberville
[__] all over the military I mean th
these these Republican politicians are
quote cowards period I mean that's just
the way it is and has been for a long
time and Donald Trump knows they're
cowards and he takes advantage of that
and that's what Kevin McCarthy's doing
this morning don't you think is it's
just it's one constituent that they're
trying to please I think it's I think I
mean yes they're absolutely cowards for
sure but I think it's deeper than that I
mean Trump is a criminal he's a lifelong
criminal you know my friend lb has done
a lot of of of writing about this down
through the years here know his father
was a basically a frontman for the
geneves crime family he's born into this
family he's involved in real estate in
New York doing all these things with
with you know and then the Russian
mafia's in on the on Trump Tower and
stuff like that and because of the the
[__] Apprentice there's this sort of
trust wash of him as well he's no he's
actually just a guy on TV and he's a
wannabe actor and he's this and that and
yes he's also that but at the end of the
day he's a criminal he's always been a
criminal and if you read um Ruth Ben
gats book strongman um strongman rather
you know she talks about corruption and
how people who are uh autocrats in these
in these corrupt uh Nations corrupt
other people um and involve them in
their crimes and that's how they link
themselves to them and force you know
someone like Kevin McCarthy to have no
choice you know I don't know what or if
anything he has on Kevin McCarthy Kevin
McCarthy might just be a spineless turd
I and and and you know like a moth to
the flame going to where he thinks the
the real power is that may be but some
of these people have participated in
Trump's crimes and we're seeing this
with with all the Jack Smith stuff we
saw this a little bit with the uh with
the house j6 committee so you know can
the Republicans get rid of him no they
can't they are stuck with him because if
they if they try to uh offload him he's
going to hit them back and he's got dirt
on him he knows how to hit them to make
it really hurt and by really hurt that
doesn't just mean lose elections really
hurt means go to prison which I think
people probably don't maybe want to do
so much so whenever I see somebody like
a Lindsey Graham who was pretty
vehemently anti-trump until he and Trump
went golfing that one day and then
suddenly it was prot Trump you know
whenever you look back and and look at
what people were saying and if they did
complete 180s in like like you know um
Saul on the road to Damascus suddenly
seeing the light about the era of ways
that's a little uh suspicious to me and
it suggests that Leverage is being used
and um he's you know he's coercing these
people and we know he coerces people
because we all watched the first
impeachment when it was presented that
he did it to president zilinsky of
Ukraine absolutely well and the other
the other thing that's clear this
morning I'm gonna I'm gonna play a
little clip here of of the
feckless nonp speaker because that's
truly what he is as a non-speaker again
he's here to pleas and he's here at the
beest of of one person and that's Donald
Trump and when you notice if you watch
the whole little diddy he did he didn't
take any questions and the reason why is
because the first question is what
evidence are you gonna find with this
inquiry and he's gonna say well that
that's a great question we have none
that's why we need the inquiry to find
the evidence which is not actually what
triggers an inquiry and to impeachment
it's evidence that triggers because you
got to have some reason to impeach and
to inquire about impeachment but they
have none they can't provide any because
they can't find any because it doesn't
exist now here is Kevin McCarthy though
giving this is just part of the of his
little feckless speech for one person in
the country and it's for one person only
and I guarantee Grandpa poopy pants is
already truth about this or whatever the
hell it's called on fraud social let's
listen today I am directing our house
committee to open a formal impeachment
inquiry into President Joe
Biden this logical next step will give
our committees the full power to gather
all the facts and answers for the
American public that's exactly what we
want to know it is exactly what we want
to know to be quite honest with you and
I I'm actually um for an impeachment
inquir and the reason why is because
this is going to be a complete utter
failure for them they number one they
don't know how to run committees it's
horrible they do not have any idea they
have no clue and they go in it they go
in it haphazardly they don't have they
do have professional staff uh especially
at leadership to handle these committees
to handle people like Daniel Goldman and
and others they they just don't have the
staff to know what's going to come at
them and it's clear in these committees
when the Democrats absolutely dunk them
in the trash that they do not have any
clue how to run a committee but also
that their staffs don't know how to do
it either um and I've talked about this
before on my show but here's the thing
is that America the American people if
you're in the Pro democracy coalition
you should actually be excited that the
Republicans are going to try to have
open hearings on this stuff right before
they shut down the government and get
blamed for that as well this should
excite you about this and the reason why
it should excite you is because it is
going to be glaringly obvious just like
it was three months ago when they hauled
in people on Twitter and these fake
whistleblowers who didn't know [__]
about [__] and and some of them were
Chinese spies and being indicted for
being CH I mean they just can't stop
stepping on rakes and this impeachment
is definitely going to be rake but let's
listen to the the latter part of this
clip and I'll let you
respond the answers I believe the
president would want to answer these
questions and allegations as well this
effort will be led by chairman James
comr at the committee on oversight in
coordination with chairman Jim Jordan
for Judiciary Committee and chairman
Jason Smith on ways and means you know I
couldn't be more excited that James comr
Jim don't report sex crimes Jordan and
Jason Smith are in charge of this I
couldn't be more excited about that
these two these three [__] are the
are the worst the worst leaders they
have to be the worst leaders and
committee chairs in modern American
history they really do they're horrible
at it well you know to be fair and I'm
just going to push back a little bit now
yeah sure you say that they have no
evidence but there there is new evidence
I don't know if you heard about this
they have found Hunter Biden's uh
Playstation h
Xbox B's Game Boy oh my God and um I
think also Hunter Biden's Pho effects
from 1987 and let me tell you yeah
that's gonna tell it all it's that's
what that's what America wants now the
the danger of all of this and I agree
with you that you know putting this into
the inquiry will turn up nothing and of
course you know Jim Jordan is a perfect
example of somebody who has his own so
many skeletons in his closet or shower
as it were that he's easy to iate but by
it's going to be one of these things now
where they're just going to impeach any
president that any Democrat that that
appears for any reason and I think
that's dangerous also they think that
now because the Democrats impeached
Trump twice um the second time for
trying to overthrow the [__]
government they can impeach Biden for
literally no reason and uh it's the same
but let me let me let me tell you on
that point because I think that's a
really good point because
there's going to be a lot of Talking
Heads out there saying oh this is
dangerous and this is but it it's I'm
gonna I'm gonna be very real and raw
right now it's not dangerous the reason
why it's not dangerous is here's why
when you use power of congress in the
appropriate way it it produces actual
results when you use the power of
congress with lies um McCarthyism was
another example in in quote our modern
history when you use it with lies
the LIE the fascism always dies with its
lies it always dies and the day of light
on fascism is coming it's coming folks
and they it doesn't come with with just
with just them talking they have to
actually do something and show that it
produces no results because folks again
Kevin McCarthy did not do this this
morning for us right like people who
have a couple brain cells to rub
together that know okay you don't have
any evidence you guys can't produce
evidence every media outlet that you go
on you're like well I wish we did it's
we're hoping we'll find some evidence
and and I forget her name and offand but
she was on um CNN and saying oh well we
need the impeachment acquired to get the
evidence like well that's not exactly
how it works either but here's the thing
is that when they are using and
weaponizing the government because
that's truly what they're doing because
they're projecting when they say
weaponizing government when they are
weaponizing government in this way where
there's no outcome that they win I
applaud that because that is the day
that fascism you pull back the curtain
you see it and their sheep their flock
will eventually maybe not all of them
but will eventually see them for the
frauds they are because they haven't
done anything on gas prices they haven't
done anything on ceiling fans or gay
beer or gas stoves or Hunter Biden I I
mean the list goes on and on they didn't
build a wall they didn't fix healthare
um they make our military stronger they
made it weaker I mean all these things
that they promis that they're going to
do I mean for instance immigration
they're like you know what we're gonna
have this policy at the border and it's
going to keep people out well now that
Joe Biden and the Biden Administration
has undone the Trump policies at the
border we have had less migrants coming
across the border and that's not that's
not just just happen stance that's
because of real actual government
working but they don't know how to
govern and I encourage them to use
government to weaponize it because it's
going to throw back the veil of their
fascism so I actually don't think it's
dangerous it feels like it in the moment
but in the long term we will history
will tell the the story of Republicans
and the real America First Nazi party
that's my opinion go ahead GRE oh I
think I think you're right that history
will I just it's it's just like anything
like it's you know if you have two
people running in an election there's
always the chance that the wrong one
will win that the that the Nazi like in
201 like in 2016 so okay you know if the
house if the if the Republicans win the
house and they Impe and they try to
impeach them they might vote to impeach
and then it's in the Senate and then
it's a thing that has to be reported on
and of course wastes time they're so
good at wasting time they're wasting
time and effort and energy and
everything it's just such a it's a I
hate to use a trump word but it's a
disgrace Tony it really is uh the way
that they waste and squander the
resources that we have like with the you
know these abortion bans that we're
seeing all in the South and and you know
we're going to fight that and make sure
that somebody from Alabama can come to
New York and not go have an abortion and
go back to Alabama without being
prosecuted but that's a tremendous use
of resources that should be used
elsewhere because we shouldn't have to
be fighting battles that were fought 50
years ago you know instead the
Republicans are making us do this again
and again and you know the law
enforcement aspect for from their side
cost money too you know they have to
invest uh law enforcement money in
chasing down some 15-year-old who was
raped by her uncle uh to prosecute her
meanwhile those cops are doing that
we're there's fewer cops on the street
protecting us from the actual criminals
who are causing danger to society so
this is all to your point about how they
do nothing they do less than nothing
they cause more problems than they solve
because they they force the rest of us
to have to worry about their [__]
instead of worrying about hey can we
create you know a better alternative
energy plan can we create uh something
to make sure that uh you know people
don't go bankrupt from from having a
medical bill they can't pay that kind of
thing um instead we have to just fight
these [__] [__] fascists all the
time and I thought I don't know I
there's a the History Channel runs World
War II stuff all the time you know how
many movies have we seen where Nazis are
the bad guys Nazis are the bad guys this
isn't hard understand right well you
know you know the funny part about that
um sentiment that Nazis are the bad guys
is Republicans the politicians the
elected Pro and the people who elect
them who are excited about them don't
think they're Nazis but the Nazis think
they're Nazis like right yeah it's it's
kind of weird in this space where
DeSantis supporters are on an overpass
in Florida right and and they're they're
they're hiling Hitler so loud that
someone down on the shoulder of an eight
Lane Highway can hear them over the
traffic noise and they're there in
support of Ronda santis and Ronda santis
will not denounce them he acts like they
don't even exist that's those are the
only 10 people that are going to vote
for him he's got well I mean it you know
um on that point so let's talk about
this for a second because there you you
talked about the danger of um of a
candidate and I watched Chris Christie
this morning now a lot of people love
Chris Christie right now which I
encourage Christie to keep pounding on
Trump Chris don't stop keep throwing
punches as hard as you possibly can but
if you think Chris Christie is an
allying democracy if you watch him and
listen to him on Fox news this morning
you are absolutely out of your mind
listen to me when I tell you this there
is not one not one Republican that is
interested in the advancement of
democracy not one it is either they're
interested in getting rid of trump so
they can gain back their power because
they know Trump is is not their power
outlet there are Republicans out there
that realize Trump is a [__] loser
most of them realize this but they know
they can't cut him off like they chained
him to their feet and threw themselves
in the ocean it's going to take a while
for that chain to rust through you know
what I mean before they can go get some
air but here's the thing is that a lot
of
Republicans know he's a loser there's
only a few that are willing to say it
but they're not saying it Chris Christie
isn't saying this stuff to to to be for
democracy yeah he's doing this stuff to
get the Republican Party back where it
was before Trump where they thin veiled
their fascism with conservatism like I
said in the beginning of the show that's
what they want to continue to do but as
long as Trump holds his flock together
by pretending to impeach Biden through
the House Republicans and through Jim
Jordan and Jim comr oh my God which H
thank you for giving us those as your
chairman and thanks for not selecting
people that could actually do the job
that's fantastic by the way um but by
doing that stuff he is trying to hold
his flock together for that nomination
right so let's talk about that for a
second is there any possibility that you
see in this moment in time that Donald
Trump is anything but the nominee come
next summer I mean anything can happen I
I agree with you on this I yeah he could
choke he could choke on a big Mach
that's possible they might elect him
anyway the the the uh you know
can we run a dead candidate I mean we've
done it before I mean isn't JFK Jr going
to be the running mate they might try it
I don't know the I I think I will say
this uh he is going to run period he's
not not gonna run because he needs to
run so he can Trot out this [__]
excuse about how you can't indict me
because it's an election and also
because that's how he's making his money
he's raising money you know wait are you
saying he's broke are you saying he's
broke is that what you're you're saying
he's always been broke broke ass well
this morning this morning he doesn't
claim to be let let me show you um
there's a tweet he's he put out this or
excuse me a tweet um yeah his a little
post on fraud social here even tweets
aren't called tweets anymore well I know
you know what's funny about that is
everyone should steal the word tweet
from Elon Musk because he can't he can't
claim it anymore but here here's Grandpa
this morning I love how he does this
page one what the [__] is he I don't
know what the [__] he's doing but here
here's what he says about the about his
wealth since you brought it up he says
in New York state case against Me by
Trump pting attorney general Leticia
James who campaigned on I will get Trump
or excuse me I will get Trump he Camp
there a case that never should have been
brought of course someone who's
criminally criminally and civil indicted
on these cases wouldn't think they'd be
brought I have easily shown and prove
proven that I am worth billions of
dollar I'm not sure why he capitalized
billions of dollars it's really weird
it's like German it's German yeah okay I
got you more than information listed on
my financial statements so he's
admitting that he he he he he lied on
his financial statements that's what
he's saying there right that's what I'm
getting all of which have very strong
disclaimer cause in protective language
and show very little debt which is not
what he claimed throughout his entire
life he's like no I use other people's
money OPM like he wrote he had people
ghost write books about OPM for him most
of which have been paid off or is
currently the hundreds of millions of
dollar cash it goes on and on and I'm
sure he's got page two page three page
four of this word salad stuff of I'm
actually rich don't believe them I'm I
even though my business is in
receivership because I'm a fraud yeah
well not not everybody can [__] on a
gold toilet you know uh but he paid for
that on layaway too I think it it I I I
think the whole thing is is ridiculous I
mean he I've always thought that he's in
debt up to his eyeballs and that's what
they have on him this is my speculation
I think coming into office he was in
debt and he got saved you know paying
somebody off psychologically is a lot
different than absolving somebody of
their debt it it it just being in debt
is a as a psychological tool is you know
it's very onor it's different than just
saying okay you're in good Financial
shape we're going to give you more money
maybe I don't need it but this guy I I
forget somebody wrote a piece about him
in 2015 2016 saying he's acts like
somebody who's broke or who's bankrupt
and went through and explained why and I
always thought that was such a an
interesting way of looking at it and you
know the tax forms that we've seen in St
he doesn't have a lot of money like he
you know nobody would lend him money
either you know the the entire US
banking system basically stopped doing
that uh after a Time and if it weren't
for that stupid show um you know he
would have gone under by now I think
that show was a Lifeline you know no no
one would have believe that he was a
good businessman if that show didn't
exist that's for sure so I got one more
thing to show you and then I want to ask
you real quickly before we leave um
because I gotta bring Texas Paul on here
um I I want to ask you about Putin and
Kim jung-un but one more thing um this
this tweet from Charlie Kirk on the
impeachment and this this just proves
that this is all at the direction and
behest of Donald Trump Charlie Kirk says
this is not about impeaching Biden what
so the impeachment of Biden is not about
impeaching Biden what I don't get that
he said it's about 9:30 it took me a
second but this is um this is the
government shutting down he said no
blank check for Ukraine which leads me
to the Putin point he said no blank
check for Jack Smith close the border as
if shutting down the government is
really going to stop any of those things
it's not really going to stop any of
those things it might it might slow down
some money to Ukraine it's not going to
stop Jack Smith and it's definitely not
going to close the border whatever the
hell that means it's actually will do
the opposite if you think about it
because the federal government controls
the border so if you shut down the
government don't give it its resources
then they won't it'll be more porous if
you really think about it Charlie but
he's an idiot he doesn't think but tell
me um about Ukraine because that's one
thing I know that you're you cover and
you stay interested in is Putin but this
morning we see Putin is meeting with Kim
Jung Un what do you make of this meeting
between them am I right to say that this
makes Putin look really [__] weak um
you are right in in saying that I mean
this guy is the black sheep of the
International Community and has been for
years and years North Korea is just
their entire economy is based on
ransomware so you know it's not great
what they're doing um it's interesting
they've always had kind of historically
a very close relationship with um the
Communist Party in Russia um initially
when North Korea went communist it was
you know mostly Stalin pulling the
strings there so um you know this is
it's always been pretty tight with the
these groups but they don't Putin likes
to pretend that he's like European and
he's a diplomat and Russia's just like
every other country and right and it's
just [__] not like Russia doesn't
follow the rule of law Russia breaks
treaties all the [__] time and that's
why when you have um Republicans like
[__] Charlie Kirk or or you know
idiots on the left saying we just want
peace man we're going to peace we're
going to have negotiations and
settlements well if we stop and have a
ceasefire now um Putin's just going to
take and keep whatever part of Ukraine
he already has you know if Mexico
invades the United States and takes
California and Arizona and New Mexico
and then Roger Waters is like we need to
stop right now and have a ceasefire that
means Mexico's going to keep California
New Mexico right we're not going to let
that happen why should we expect Ukraine
to let that happen they're not going to
let that happen so um they couch these
things under the guise of Peace but it's
all [__] but Putin doesn't he
doesn't keep his word there were there
were treaties signed in
1996 well after the dissolution of the
of the uh Soviet Union Ukraine had more
nuclear weapons than any country in the
world except for the United States in
Russia and in 96 they signed an
agreement and gave all of the nukes back
to Russia as part of the deescalation
thing and one of the you know cotal in
that agreement was that hey don't invade
us which of course they don't pay any
attention to they just they invaded in
2014 we the West didn't really feel like
making a big deal about it at the time
when they took Crimea right so we
slapped on some sanctions which they I
think we there's audio of them laughing
about uh from the Kremlin that we have
and uh and and then he's been you know
biting his time waiting for a moment to
pounce he's not allowed to do this this
is a violation of international law so
the idea that he's going to come to some
agreement that he's going to uphold is
is is batshit we can't negotiate with
this guy like he's a normal Diplomat
because he's not he is a a genocidal
madman with those aims so um looking
around the map of the world you know one
of the things Biden one of the many
things Biden has done really well is
United the countries of NATO and the
other Democratic allies against this guy
and it's working you know it's the the
economic stuff isn't quite as crushing
as it could be or maybe will be but he's
now at the point where he's got to go
hang out with North Korea that's like
being you know you're in the high school
you're being kicked out of the cool kids
club and you're I mean all the way in
the back you're one of the smelly kids
now you're that table now you're at that
table now cuz that guy is you know and
uh I don't know I you know does Trump
want in on this manaja does he want it
like the Republicans really like this
and it and it it's really weird that the
Republicans love Putin and then Putin's
like you know I'm so desperate I got to
go get um weapons from Kim jung-un and
they're like yeah that's that we like
that too for whatever reason we can make
makeup because you know that's what they
do is is lie and there there's no
there's no um consistency in any of
their argu it's you can't argue with
them it's like a [__] cat with the
laser pointer it's over there no I'm GNA
do this about this are they the cat or
they the laser pointer which I I don't I
I don't they're the cat I guess point no
I I thought I figured that their their
supporters were the cat and and the
elected politicians are the laser
pointer you know I think here over here
it's so or or the or the [__]
right-wing media which is just well that
is true that is true well we're fighting
hard against the right-wing media as
here on this show the Tony Michaels
podcast but also on on your great pieces
of media whether it be the substack
whether it be the podcast or rather it
be the the live show on Fridays with lb
Lincoln's Bible everyone go to the links
down below great give us one more
Shameless plug before we go to break
yeah if you go you know again my
substack is really the bread and butter
because I'm a writer at the end of the
day so that's the that's the main thing
if you just go to uh Greg O.S substack
docomo and is a real problem um I've got
lots of stuff about Leonard Leo in the
Supreme Court you know we wrote a great
piece about Kavanaugh uh back in the day
so I write a lot about these uh [__]
as lb calls them and um you know it it's
uh there's a out there so I've got that
I've got the podcast which you are
coming on this very Friday this is a
home and home for us and we we'll get
the link out to everyone so they can
listen to that that it's good it's a
good one I'm excited for it and uh again
Friday Friday at 8 Eastern five Pacific
it's 5'8 come check us out good well
thank thank you for joining us Greg I
appreciate it my friend and everyone go
down to the links below uh follow Greg
check out his work it's it's worth a
shot and I I I can't wait to hear the
Friday show and hear myself ramble on
and on and on I'm just kidding I can't
wait for it I really I really am I'm
excited everyone knows I love the talk
that that's my favorite thing to do so
thank you Greg for joining us you gota
you gotta come back again and and let's
catch up on the Senate uh as some more
news comes out about the Senate uh and
more about the Supreme Court and this
Tommy tuber bille and how ridiculous the
Senate is and I'm sure he have some
great words to give us on glitch
McConnell I mean Mitch McConnell excuse
me I like glitch mcconell that's I I I I
I I digress thank you Greg for joining
us everyone stick around we'll be right
back thanks T right after this
break what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast fellow Patriots what would you
do if there was a trump supporter right
in front of you crying in pain because
they have to live under communist te
tyny we know what you would do you'd
reach out and give that true American a
hand now here's your chance for only $50
a day you can help us help those true
Americans recover from Biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those Trump
supporters and this is that moment send
your donation via venmo to the real
president Donald J Trump it's only $50 a
day recurring and it means you'll get
these Trump supporters the critical help
they so desperately need to survive
under this false regime please donate
now because those Trump supporters you
just saw can't wait another
moment [__] them [__] [__] them [__]
[__] them [__] them we're back to the
Tony Michaels
podcast what welcome back to the
show
Greg go the links down below check out
Greg's
substack also check out his podcast this
Friday I'm on there you're not going to
want to miss that episode and check out
his live show on Friday with Lincoln
Bibles the 5'8 the link are down below
in the
description we got Texas Paul coming but
I want to give you some announcements
it's very important that I give you this
news today right after this show on
YouTube and twitch you will be directed
to what was that live the very first
episode of what was that live with the
guy with the last name
sanes so make sure you stick around
after the show for gabes live one hour
what was that you're not going to want
to miss it it's the very first one
please please go and support him follow
his channel as we move to his show after
this show on YouTube um and and if
you're on Facebook which I know a lot of
you are on Facebook we're getting more
and more viewers on Facebook so um if
you're on Facebook he's not on Facebook
he won't be airing it on Facebook so
you'll have to come to YouTube or twitch
um but again just type in I am Gabe
Sanchez I am Gabe Sanchez or go to I am
gab
sanchez. you will find the links there
to get to the what was that live right
after show he'll probably be joining us
at the top of the the
hour um before that and but right now
it's Tuesday it's Taco Tuesday and it's
Texas Paul Tuesday you know that's we
have Texas Paul Texas Paul my friend how
are you
today you you got to unmute your mic
that would that would help out you gotta
unmute your mic that would that would
help I am wonderful man it's pumpkin
spice time
baby oh my God are you are you on are
you on a pumpkin spice train are you a
I'm on a pumpkin spice hi brother I've
had like six cups this morning I'm tell
oh my God Jesus Christ no wonder no
wonder I I thought you were getting up
three or four times I I figured it was
because you'd been drinking so much
pumpkin spice coffee you had to piss so
much is that what it was or were you
going getting more pumpkin spice that
too but you know as a courtesy man you
know I will piss in the trash can so I
don't no no no you if you need to piss
if you need to piss just let me know I
I'll let you uh that is that is
absolutely fine um you know we were
talking about um glitch McConnell at the
very end there and I want to get your uh
your take on Vladimir Putin um meeting
with Kim jung-un I think it's actually
laughable this is hilarious um
Republicans step on another rake by
thinking he's some kind of strong strong
leader in the world and he's the right
one in this situation when he's invading
Sovereign Nations and now he has to beg
beg at Kim jung-un the murderous
dictator of North Korea or to give him
some [__] help on weapons but the
first thing I want to get artillery
shells and bullets yeah well artillery
shells and and dumb artill shells at
that that that's that's the right well
you know it would be it would be
something if you start a war to make
sure you have enough artillery shells
that would be a good thing to probably
do you know what I mean I mean a really
smart leader would make sure that they
have enough Weaponry at least the shells
to use uh at War if you're going to
invade a sovereign country and be a
murderous dictator and commit war crimes
against women and children but I digress
from that we'll get back to that first
thing I want to go to is glitch
McConnell uh you know Rona McDaniel
Romney do you know this this [__]
[__] you know her I'm sorry I use the
word that's the word that I use that's
what she is and you're GNA see it in
this clip here they're talking about
Biden and a agism on Fox News the trader
TV news network but what is funny about
this is she walks right into the truth
and they serve it up to her and it is
awkward as [__] watch this I mean I just
think you see Biden go vacant you see
this lost stare it's concerning anybody
who's had family m members who've had
that moment and and he's the president
of United States it's deeply concerning
I don't think people see that with
Donald Trump or anybody on our side of
the aisle do you see that do you see
that with Mitch
McConnell he's had an illness I I quite
at the same I talked to Mitch the other
day and he sounded fine as sharp as
ever ah you you lying
[__] I mean you know what
they're just Shameless man they're just
Shameless and the reason why is because
this audience on Fox News wants her to
lie to him like that they they want to
they want to be lied to they want to be
told that Joe Biden can't put two
thoughts together but Mitch McConnell
when you watch him have a mini stroke in
front of you in front of a [__]
microphone that's just that's just old
Mitchy having a a brain fart get the
[__] out of here man what do you make of
this you never in your life in your life
have you ever seen the president of the
United States uh and lock up freeze
frame for over 30 seconds and somebody
have to come rescue him never have you
seen anything close to that you know Joe
Biden had had not only is he you know
all there mentally I mean he's kicking
their ass left and right I mean he is
just destroying them politically and
then they want to turn around and say
well he you know he he's too old he's
too you know [__] you're trying
to nominate Donald jackass Jessica Trump
I'm gonna steal that by the way that was
beautiful Donald Jessica Trump uh yeah
yeah go ahead you this guy is like three
what three years you know within three
years of of of Joe Biden and you're
sitting here trying to say oh well you
know Joe Biden's SCH my ass man Joe
Biden has a [__]
stutter and that man is outc
communicating the entire Republican
party well and he's also he's also being
an actual world leader now this is this
is Ducey and Reporting live on the
ground in Vietnam about about Joe Biden
and he absolutely crushes the hopes and
dreams here on the trader TV News
Network that he works for Fox News watch
this [__] as he describes what Joe Biden
is doing in Vietnam he has been
basically working all through the night
at the equivalent of an all nighter
eastern time so he's probably pretty
tired pretty jet lagged but uh yeah you
see H but but what did I just say right
well I mean he can't sometimes they
stumble into the truth Texas Paul and
they say it out loud and when they say
the truth out loud it doesn't suit their
narrative and this narrative somehow
that Joe Biden is somehow um old or
whatever or whatever the hell they say
is all [__] it's all bull does he
walk slow sure he's sure whatever but he
can ride a [__] bike I've never seen
Trump you'll never see Trump on a
[__] bike in his life and Ducey here
is like yeah he's been pulling all
nighters pulling all nighters and he's
working his ass off and he's doing that
folks for America okay he's not pulling
all nighter and posting on some [__]
social media site about his 91 felonies
that he's indicted for he's not
attacking prosecutors and attacking
Witnesses on his [__] social media
account Time Time and Time and Time
Again reposting all kinds of lies and
[__] he's working he's putting on
his [__] shoes and doing his job and
Ducey knows it Ducey has to say it live
on Fox News which is hilarious and I
love it keep going you [__] idiots
keep lying but that's the way they do
Texas Paul they lie they lie yeah well
you go to you go back to FDR you never
saw a thing about
his you know his illness his polio none
of that you didn't know he was
wheelchair ridden for the first two
terms he was in office Joe
Biden I you know I hate to tell you this
folks Joe Biden hurt his back he did
that's why he walks sometimes you see
him walk like like he's got a stick
shoved up his ass that is why because he
has injured his back but he's not going
out for surgery because of the stupid
[__] narrative about you know is he
too old is he this he could go have
freaking back surgery and take care of
that that walk that he has but he won't
do it he's not going to take the time
off he's working he's being a world
leader you know he's pulling all
nighters in freaking Vietnam you know
you know he's at the G20 in India he's
busting ass so yeah they're going to
make fun of the way the guy walks but I
guarantee you I've had back surgery Tony
let me tell you I know that walk very
well that walk where you don't turn your
head you don't anything you just walk
straight up and you take Little Steps
been there dude been there you know
there's a lot of people that commit
freaking suicide over that kind of pain
this man is running a [__] country
while he's dealing with this and it's
not slowing him down at all at all it's
not slowing him down at all you know
what um since he's got back problems um
and he's got so much pain you know
there's one thing that does have is a
spine and that's one thing that Kevin
McCarthy doesn't have so Kevin McCarthy
is bound to not have back problems
because he doesn't have a spine but
here's a report before the press
conference this morning and see if you
can catch the hint of what Republicans
don't have see if you can catch it and
new this morning Pete Angley and Brian
we've learned that house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy is later this week going to
embrace the idea of launching an
impeachment inquiry meaning the ball is
starting to move a little bit closer to
that potential goal line that some
Republicans say they want secure guys do
they have the votes for it uh for the
impeachment inquiry to be launched I
would imagine that they would have the
votes to do that of course whether or
not they get to the the full measure of
an impeachment uh that's to be unseen
but I would imagine with the speaker
saying let's launch the inquiry I can't
imagine that he would do that if he
didn't feel like he had the support to
do oh man let me tell you something they
don't have the votes let me let me let
me give you some reassurance they don't
have the votes that's what that means
they do not have the votes and Kevin
McCarthy didn't allude to the fact that
they have the votes this morning either
go ahead and even that jackass Ken Buck
is like what the hell are you doing
impeachment inquiry there's no such
thing you you you do this and and you
either have evidence in which you can
vote for an impeachment or you don't
have evidence
[__] thing is an impeachment inquiry
and Kim Buck's like you look like idiots
you're going to make us look like idiots
because now you're you're saying we look
like idiots but hey whole [__] world
watch us look like idiots good I mean
it's well exactly and they're they're
going to do this before they even look
more like fools that they can't govern
when they can't keep the government open
and then they try to blame it on coid
lockdowns because I guar godamn te you
that's what they're going to do but
here's here's a longer statement I
played a short part of um non-speaker of
the house Kevin McCarthy's statement
this morning spineless never having back
problems Kevin McCarthy's he's Trump's
puppet do I need to come up with any
more [__] names for this [__]
feckless idiot let's listen to Kevin
McCarthy here tell us how he doesn't
have the votes for impeachment but Trump
wants him to impeach Biden so he has to
do something so let's listen you know
the months that we were gone and the
weeks House Republicans have uncovered
serious incredible allegations into
President Biden's conduct okay now we're
GNA we're going to walk through each
individual where did he saying he didn't
say evidence he said allegations meaning
there's been a lot of people including
James comr and Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan going on Fox News
including marjerie Taylor green and Matt
gats on their stupid [__] shows
claiming allegations that Joe Biden has
committed crimes which is all
allegations it's all [__] folks
there's no evidence of this whatsoever
that's why he has to say there's
allegations listen to his words we'll
break them down as he
goes taken together these allegations
paint a picture of a culture of
corruption again no evidence just
allegations and painting a picture
meaning creating a narrative around
[__]
narratives now here's what we know so
far yeah through our investigations we
have found that President Biden did lie
no you didn't to the
people about his own knowledge of his
family's foreign business dealings no
you didn't no you didn't I Witnesses
have testified that the president joined
on multiple phone calls what the [__]
mle interactions dinners resulted in
cars and millions of dollars oh my God
Texas Paul he ate meals he ate meals
with can you imagine can you imagine in
Washington DC a politician and having
meals with people get the [__] out of
here is he serious oh my God he had a
son that he was helping deal with an
addiction issue and they he called him
Tony he was on the phone with his son
son we we know we know that calling your
son is impeachable we know that that is
the case absolutely 100% into his son's
and his son's business
partners we know that bank records show
that nearly $20 million in payments were
directed to the Biden family members and
Associates through various shell
companies are they impeaching the entire
Biden family is that what they're doing
is that what he's saying no what he's
saying is that Hunter Biden makes bank
right he makes a lot of money and shell
companies these aren't shell companies
these are [__] companies these the he
is a you know an advisor he is a
consultant he is a Lobby
companies that make money every goddamn
day he's actually making money and
Republicans can't recognize that [__]
because they've got [__] Trump this
[__] [__] living on a goddamn credit
card all the time they don't recognize
what making money actually looks like
well the other thing to the other thing
that's crazy is they act like there's no
other Consultants out there that are
addicted to drugs and prostitutes or no
lobbyist in Washington are addicted to
drugs and prostitutes get the [__] out
of here you guys are having cocaine sex
orgies tell me about Co drugs and
prostitutes again Kevin McCarthy all
right let's keep going let's see if he
comes up with something that is actually
impeachable the treasury Department
alone has more than 150
transactions involving the Biden family
and other business associates that were
flagged as suspicious activity that's
[__] they aren't flagged as
suspicious activity they flag because
they're over $10,000 you dumb son of a
[__] Jesus chist exactly learn the
learn the [__] system would you
please by US
Banks even a trusted FBI informant has
alleged a bribe to the Biden family nope
[__] fired informant a [__] fired
FBI
inform let's let's be clear they have no
[__] trusted anybody right every one
of the witnesses they pulled up have
humiliated them they're either being
paid by cash Patel they're under
investigation by the FBI they're [__]
spies you have no trusted informant you
know what's funny you know what's funny
you know why he won't say their name
because he can't say their he can't say
their name in this statement he can't
say their name in the statement because
people could go Google that [__] and
they could find out exactly who these
[__] are and who they aren't
and their frauds well let's keep going
let's see if he comes up with anything
that is even remotely close to
impeachable Biden used his official
office to coordinate with Hunter Biden's
business partners about hunter's role in
bisma a Ukrainian Energy
company
finally despite these serious
allegations it appears that the
president's family has been offered
special treatment by Biden's own
Administration treatment that not even
so like hey you come to the White House
you're my family is that what he's
talking what the [__] is he talking
about yeah he his his granddaughter got
married at the White House oh my God oh
my God that hasn't [__] happened over
and over again well you know what you
know what's crazy you know what's crazy
you know what's crazy you know what
Donald Trump did in
2020 he had he he he was nominated at
the White House you remember that he
accepted and you don't do that well you
don't do that so is that him Miss using
his office I don't know seems like it's
a lot of projection here but keep going
let's see if there's something that is
that just stands out as impeachable for
an impeachment inquiry not otherwise
would have received that they were not
related to the president yeah no [__]
Sherlock these are allegations of abuse
of power obstruction and Corruption
obstruction what obstruction they wer
further investigation by the House of
Representatives
that's why today I am directing our
house committee to open a formal to do
the same old [__] over
again this logical Next Step will give
our committees the full power to gather
all the facts and answers for the
American public that's exactly what we
want to know you noticed their
committees already had subpoena power
what the [__] are you talking about you
know you know what's funny about this if
you go back and listen to this he does
not say the word evidence one time he
doesn't say it one time and the reason
why he does not say the word evidence
one time is because they have not a
shred of it of any of these allegations
against Joe Biden that are and half of
them aren't even impeachable in the
first place most of these allegations
aren't even impeachable like oh there's
150 transactions that the bank flagged
from his family the [__] that got to
do with it so there's 150 transactions
that were over $10,000 that didn't go to
Joe Biden what the [__] is your point
what the [__] is the point in even
saying that [__] the reason why is
because they have nothing else to say
Texas Paul they have nothing else to say
you know I've said it over and over and
over again if you're a consultant if if
I'm going to go consult for somebody in
China tomorrow which is perfectly
perfectly [__] legal if I want to go
consult for somebody in China I have to
open up a company in China I did it's
their law I have to do it if I want to
buy furniture I have to have accounts
set up in China to to lease Furniture to
lease office space I have to set up bank
accounts for my customer to transfer me
money in China I have to that's part of
Consulting and these [__] are sitting
here saying oh man Hunter Biden he had a
foreign bank account and the treasury
Department flagged it well yeah they're
flag every damn dollar I bring in from
China because they're going to want to
know what kind of Consulting are you
doing right what are you up to and it
doesn't matter who you
are yeah the form needs to be renamed
because it's called a suspicious
activity report is what it's called it
is [__] there's nothing suspicious
about it Hunter Biden said here's my
[__] books because that's the law
that is the law he is done all of his
registrations and that's how Consulting
works I've seen Marge do this over and
over again she'll go and she'll talk
like oh this is suspicious this is a
crime he opened a bank account and sent
money to his to this guy you know and
that's his partner in the United States
he was hiding the money no [__]
his partner runs the books he does the
the Consulting and his partner runs the
books so they moved it they moved it
from their customers Bank account that
you set up to service their Customer
because
Tony if I'm bidding to to be
your you know consultant
Tony and I tell you ah [__] you Tony you
want to do business with me you come to
Texas and there's five other people that
say you know what I'll come to you I'll
be there tomorrow I'll have a local
[__] bank I'll set up a bank account
in your bank so that all you have to do
is make a phone call and transfer money
whenever you need to move money M are
you g to do business with me or are you
going to do business with the smart
[__] people that service you you know
and they they try to act like this is a
crime but here's the thing here's the
thing what the [__] does this have to do
with Joe Biden everything you said was
about Hunter Biden what the [__] does it
have to do with Joe
Biden and you know what pisses me off
more than anything you know what pisses
me off about Kevin McCarthy doing this
[__] this morning pisses me off more
than anything is I sit here and [__]
defend Joe Biden which is something I do
not like to do with my air time I don't
want to have to sit here and defend Joe
Biden when he doesn't need defending
it's [__] ridiculous that we have to
do this nonsense but this is where they
put us this is this stupidity um and I
want to show you some more stupidity in
the Republican party that's right I'm
gonna say it a lot of people love Chris
Christie right now can I throw one more
little point out there yeah go ahead
they say the Biden family the Biden
family okay tax laws are really straight
forward if if I'm running into a tax
liability my my accountant's going to
call me and say dude you're going to
have to to write a check to the
government okay so what I'll do is I
will set up a trust for my
granddaughter and I will transfer her
money and instead of giving it to the
government I'll give it to my
granddaughter and it's tax-free and
there goes my tax liability rep
Republicans Republicans have set up laws
for for decades and decades and decades
to make sure that the rich can hand
their wealth over to to their to their
[__] families without exactly and
Hunter Biden did that he he he took
nieces he took every and the dude makes
so much cash he's like okay I'm gonna
have a tax liability and he sets up
trusts for [__] family members that
he takes care of he takes care of his
family Tony well tell
that that's the Biden crime family
because the [__] 13-year-old niece
got 10 grand for Hunter Biden so so that
he didn't have to pay taxes on
itge so she could go to college yeah
it's [__] ridiculous exactly well
these are all brain dead idiots anyways
even this guy that's right I said it
Chris Christie's a [__] idiot now a
lot of people are gonna hate me for this
too because Chris Christie is the only
one punching on Donald Trump really I
mean ASA Hutchinson but who gives a [__]
about him no one even knows who he is
but Chris Christie is one of the only
ones punching on Donald Trump but again
folks he's not an ally for democracy I'm
gonna show you this clip on on Trader TV
News Network FOX News here I use the
word news lightly okay but here's the
thing everyone loves Chris Christie
right now but I'm gonna show you why you
can't trust Chris Christie because folks
I'm gonna tell you if there's one of
these [__] Republicans who can beat
Joe Biden if they had their [__]
together and they knew what was good for
them they would nominate Chris Christie
they would nominate Chris Christie I'm
telling you right now for sure 100% he's
the only one standing on that stage that
would give Joe Biden a run for his money
and the reason why is because Chris
Christie is a damn good retail
politician that's why he was the New
Jersey governor twice even after [__]
stuffing up the bridge but Chris
Christie here is no [__] Ally of
democracy listen to the [__] lies
that he sells after he gets your
attention about punching on Trump listen
what he did on Election night to me
disqualified him from being president
the United States again okay so first
off on Election night Chris really it
took you to election night when he came
out and started to spread his lies the
lies beforehand all the setup for that
[__] before that he said look I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna give the results and
all
this I'm not gonna give the results I'm
not gonna give the results to the
election I'm not going to tell you
whether I concede or not come on Chris
come on Chris he was setting you up for
what you say is so egregious but let's
continue when you go in front of the
American people and lie to them on
Election night and say that you know the
election's been stolen when you had no
evidence then and you have no evidence
now that it was stolen because it wasn't
um he lost to Joe Biden now I know his
fragile ego can't deal with the idea
that he lost to somebody like Joe Biden
who had never beaten anybody outside the
state of Delaware before there guess
what Donald you lost to Joe Biden and
everything Joe Biden has done to harm
this country since then is your
responsibility
because your selfishness your
self-centeredness put him in the white
house so there you go if you think if
you think if you think Chris Christie is
an Allied democracy I give you that as
evidence that he's not number one he's
lying about Biden I Joe Biden was the
vice president of the United States on
the ticket I believe I don't think he
was handed that by anyone I I I actually
I mean I remember him being the vice
president I don't know about you I mean
maybe maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm crazy
but I remember Joe Biden being vice
president I think that's the reason why
they want to impeach him isn't it Texas
Paul because he was vice president
somehow he was using that office so
Chris Christie saying that Vice Joe
Biden has never won an election outside
Delaware he's full of [__] um and the
other thing too is that you notice Chris
Christie is using Donald his punches
with Donald Trump to attract people who
would be in the pro-democracy Coalition
I'm telling you people I'm telling you
this this [__] from Chris Christie is
good old conservat fascism thin Bale
with conservatism type [__] where
they're playing the old he's playing the
old trick oroo on you so don't act like
Chris chrisy is some kind of [__]
Ally for democ I mean hey I'm not I'm
not gonna stop Chris Christie I'm gonna
tell him to keep punching on Trump
because we need to draw these wedges but
you need to know who Chris Christie is
uh there's a venmo uh chat here from
from Peter says GOP reasoning for
impeachment is based on the scene of the
office where Michael wants to fire him I
have cause and it because I hate him
that's just that's it they they want to
impeach him because they [__] hate
him and the reason why they hate him is
exactly what Chris Christie said Joe
Biden whipped Donald Trump's ass in the
last election they he got his ass handed
to him in the last election and I
believe um Texas Paul that Donald Trump
will get his ass handed to him in the
next election as if they nominate him so
what do you think about Chris Christie
here though you know it's that same old
[__] about you know just just
there's this entire freaking Fantasy
Land in Republican world did you hear
him say about all the terrible things
that Joe Biden did to America is your
fault you know what terrible things you
jackass well he hey he lowered drug
prices Texas Paul he did that you know
what else he got rule Broadband for
crying out loud and and bridges that
they've been trying to repair forever he
[__] got legislation pass to repair
those those bridges can you [__]
imagine oh and he gave relief to
millions of Americans as we were coming
out of coid oh and and he's encouraged
inflation reduction in this country you
the terrible things that the president
of the United States has done the [__]
out of here with everybody says you know
we've we've had that soft Landing they
were looking for and and you know the
chip act we're we're now leading the
world in semiconductor production that
used to be used to be Taiwan now we're
leading the world and
semi you bastard that sounds terrible
that sounds terrible American jobs
that's that's what Republicans don't
want and that's what they truly don't
want they don't want the economy to do
well they want the economy to crash
that's why they're going to shut down
the government
that's you know all you know Arizona you
know all those tech jobs that are you
know floating into Arizona you've never
seen a $45 an hour job before for a
working stiff you don't know what the
hell that looks like well there they are
they're yours cuz that godamn Joe bid
you know I mean come on people come on
you know I'm so sick of I am so sick and
damn tired of the corporate media Tony I
you know I Googled a little bit ago
because I wanted to get the latest list
of all the people that Tommy
tuberville's promotions he's held up the
first thing that popped up was a thing
from AP that says Tommy tuberville is
holding up promotions because of
abortion in the Army abortion
regulations [__] Tommy tuberville
started this because he was defending
white supremacist in the military that's
where it started that's when he first
put his hold on because the the military
was rooting saying they're gonna root
out white supremacy and Tommy tuberville
said Oh no you're not and put a hold on
promotions then somebody whispered it in
his ear hey you dumbass you complete
utter freaking dumbass you can't do that
they'll destroy us say it's about
abortion then you can do any damn thing
you want
well you know where they're going with
this you know where they're going with
that the Tommy T reveal thing and then
I'm gonna I'm going to show you Matt G's
response on the house floor to Kevin
McCarthy um you know what they're going
with the Tommy tuberville thing and the
abortion thing they're going to well you
know we could solve this whole problem
if women weren't in the military that's
where they're headed that's where
they're [__] headed they're going to
start saying it online they're GNA start
saying it on TV these Republicans are
like you know what you're right we can
just get rid of this whole thing this
whole this whole thing can be gone if
women aren't in the military that's what
the [__] they're going to start saying
speaking of dumbb shits and really
stupid ideas it's a really dumb idea to
put this guy in a seat of Congress but
here's Matt gance on the floor
apparently responding to Kevin McCarthy
today let's let's listen to see if
there's a if there's a civil war brewing
and it's not in our country maybe it's
in their party let's listen on this very
floor in January the whole world
witnessed a historic contest for house
Speaker I rise today to serve notice Mr
Speaker you are out of compliance with
the agreement that allowed you to assume
this role the path forward for the House
of Representatives is to either bring
you into immediate total compliance or
remove you pursuant to a motion to
vacate the chair we have had no vote on
term limits or on balance budgets as the
agreement demanded and required there's
been no full release of the January 6
tapes as you promised there has been
insufficient accountability for the
Biden crime family and instead of
cutting spending to raise the debt limit
you relied on budgetary gimmicks and
recisions so that you ultimately ended
up serving as the valet to underwrite
Biden's debt and Advance his spending
agenda Mr Speaker you boasted in January
that we would use the power of the
subpoena and the power of the purse but
here we are eight months later and we
haven't even sent the first subpoena to
Hunter Biden that's how you know that
the rush
and you know somewhat rattled
performance you just saw from the
speaker isn't real at this point during
Democrat control over the House of
Representatives they had already brought
in Don Jr three times and we haven't
even sent the first subpoena to Hunter
Biden power of the subpoena and power of
the purse only thing the 118th Congress
is known for at this point is electing
Kevin McCarthy's speaker and underr
writing Biden's debt and unfortunately
there's only one of those things we can
remediate at this time you know what
Texas Paul I couldn't agree with Matt
gatore oh these [__] idiots you know
what's you know what's great about this
you know what's great about this I've
been telling the audience all morning
that this is this is all bad for
Republicans that this oh because on this
morning on the mainstream media like
this is dangerous this this is not
dangerous this is their little [__]
theater charade that they're playing out
in the House of Representatives it is
not going to go any further than a bunch
of [__] hot air because that's all
they are and Matt Gat is laying it out
for you they promis this they promis
that they promis this they promis that
and they can't deliver any of that [__]
because they're feckless that's one
thing that Matt gats doesn't understand
is all those things that he's talking
about are all on the foundation of lies
and deceit and when you when you build
your entire promise your entire platform
on lies and deceit as its foundation it
will crumble from out out from under you
and and folks I know it feels like we're
in a time that it's not crumbling yet
but trust me the cranks are there and
they are showing and this is an example
of that and we should keep encouraging
these morons to fight this out and if
you're not I'm I'm cheering for an
impeachment inquiry a matter of fact
let's do it [__] impeachment
inquiry today tomorrow into next month
and into next year let's do it you dumb
sons of [__] because this is the
result of what is going to happen to the
Republicans exactly what Matt Gat is
doing on the floor as Kevin McCarthy
gives the House Republicans what he
thinks they want and then Matt turns on
him it's [__]
incredible yeah I I I really do not know
other than Donald Trump himself who
Kevin McCarthy is serving here I mean it
doesn't help him with his base because
they get humiliated again you saw his
base hunting against him hey you
promised us there would be evidence hey
you promised us you know that that that
there would be you know hearings where
we got them these hearings suck man they
made us look
bad okay let's do that on a larger scale
you know let's do that where every
member of the freaking house is sitting
there and you've got to face Jasmine
Crockett you you know you've gotta F I
mean you have
idea yeah you have no idea what a gift
this is you're gonna talk about your
Witness
and God forbid you call that witness God
forbid you actually call that witness
instead of standing on the floor in a
bunch of [__] postering [__] and
inventing [__] that he said and then
they just embarrass you when you turn
your witness over to actual the actual
Democrats who will get their say in this
right you're G look this
is uh well you know what else is a gift
is John fed's mustache oh my God I don't
know if you've seen this thing but holy
[__] but apparently I haven't seen this
clip yet but apparently he destroys
fascist in this clip so I'm going to
play it let's listen ask you about this
news that speaker McCarthy has formally
launched an impeachment or has said he's
going to oh my god really oh my gosh you
know oh it's
devastating don't do it please don't do
it oh
no I don't know if you know but this is
the way politicians should be acting
towards this it's not oh my God this is
dangerous this is no they should
democrats should be like yeah let's do
this [__] you want to do this political
thing and you want to not do the work of
your constituents you want to go down
this road of just a an endless slug of
you getting your ass kicked fine by me
fine by me let's do that kind of [__]
and also let's do this uh while we're
talking about it let's bring in someone
oh man he's late today I don't know I
don't know this guy I don't know if
he'll ever appear on this show again I I
might just I don't know it depends on
how how this episode goes I guess so I
guess so it could sorry I got distracted
I was watching I was watching the new
Apple event I was too invested into it
the Apple event what what it's more
exciting to me than you know until I
know until I get the final the final
display the final show of Kevin McCarthy
being kicked out as Speaker oh yeah I
was like will have to do for right now
so do you think do you think um seeing
the because I I noticed that you noticed
the clip from Matt
gats oh yeah yeah so do you think Kevin
McCarthy R because he's like he rushed
to do this this morning do you think
Kevin McCarthy got word that Matt gats
was gonna do this on the floor so he ran
out and like no no we're totally gonna
impeach him I swear to God we're gonna
impeach him and the Matt gu is like you
know what I'm gonna say this anyways I
don't give a [__] like because they want
to fight each other right they don't
care I said in a tweet and I'll cover it
in uh during the the my show in 17
minutes you have a show yeah dude
inaugural live who who wait a second
tell tell everyone what this show is
about then I I had no clue I mean who
knew man who knew
so as some people may know I have a a
show that I I release one or two
episodes that's you know uh satirical
news show I talk about current events I
break them down and I try to make
everyone feel a little bit better by
laughing as you know just some just
cathartic release really is what the
show's all about so I'm now taking that
show which is a uh scripted edited show
and I'm bringing you the live version
which is giving you insight into how I
slew through the internet and find these
stories kind of the rabbit hole that I
go down as well as just the stories I'm
not cover actual Show's upit are you g
to show the audience how your brain
works this sounds very we're going to do
it's be like the Magic School Bus
everyone's get onard
andle right into my brain into the guy
with the last name Sanchez's brain okay
so this show is gonna air right after
this show on Tuesdays Wednesdays and
Thursdays today is the very first
episode of what was that live with Gabe
Sanchez so everyone don't forget to
stick around here on YouTube or on
Twitch you're going to go direct
directly into his live show um this is a
good point to talk talk about this I
think since you're here you know yeah
okay I well I mentioned it a few times
on the show today I just want to make
sure everyone understands exactly what
is GNA happen is that if you're on
YouTube on the main YouTube channel and
on Twitch you'll go directly into gabes
show so you won't have to go anywhere
it'll be almost like it'll almost be
like we're the mainstream media but
we're not the mainstream media if that
makes sense yeah that makes sense so
streaming mainly into the next show
that's right streaming into the next
show just not media streaming type stuff
right we're not mainstream media type
stuff so everyone stick around after the
show you're gonna see that do you have
anything you have anything you want to
lead us into um for the show topic that
you want to talk about I'm obviously
gonna talk about Kevin McCarthy and
these Republicans that have no evidence
no story no nothing whatsoever I'm going
to be talking about September 11th and
what the Republican party did or rather
Fox News which will be a more um I'll
give you a condensed version but that's
gonna be its own solo episode is this
their post of never forget and they're
like yeah we'll never forget that you
voted against the victims of 911 like
yeah we also never forget that Donald
Trump had a or planned to have a secret
meeting with the Taliban how
disrespectful right let's call out the
real people or the fact that Donald
Trump wasn't anywhere to be seen at any
of the events Memorial sites or anything
during the 20th anniversary that guy was
nowhere to be seen well hey hey hey hey
hey easy easy the president of United
States is overseas doing the work of a
world leader it seems like you know how
much did that piss you off that that
after after the G20 and and you know the
the Vietnam trip the president's on his
way home and he stops in Alaska to be
with our soldiers in Alaska which by the
way they prepare for a Russian invasion
every day I don't know if you know this
but if if we ever go to war with Russia
it's going to be through freaking Alaska
yeah he sits down with them has you know
breaks spread with them has a great
meeting thanks them is there and then
Fox News is you know well the president
didn't attend any of the events in New
York no he didn't attend the events in
New York because he's flying in from the
other side of the freaking world doing
your business you know I mean there's
also the other aspect of the reason he's
in Anchorage your flying Air Force One
in and I don't know if people understand
how I don't know uh gasoline or diesel
works or you know you need to refuel
certain times it's like when you drive
your car and it's like uhoh tanks going
unempty Republicans don't Republicans
don't understand these things I mean the
only thing they know about gas tanks or
or gas stations are the prices with a
Joe Biden I did that and he lowered the
gas prices you're welcome I I hear I
hear Joe Biden's gonna ban gas tanks um
he's gonna ban them and and you're only
I understand and you're only going to be
able to put two gallons of gas in each
gas tank each week because he's going to
ban that too so um you know stuff that
margorie Taylor green would say here's
margerie Taylor Green's little quip here
about the impeachment inquiry which
isn't um a thing again keep going you
[__] feckless idiots throw that rake
out and stomp on that some [__] let's
see how she Stomps on the rake here uh
it's simple it doesn't hurt them at all
they're doing a great job for their
districts it's not a political
impeachment inquiry uh so they have
nothing to be concerned about it's the
right thing for us to do to go after
corruption oh she's talking about how
they don't have the votes okay so here's
the thing here's the thing if if you're
listening out there why this impeachment
thing is really stupid and and if and if
Republicans wanted to continue as a
political party they wouldn't do this um
and if they want to kill themselves as a
political party which are really already
dead we're just dragging around the dead
body of the Republican party in this
country to be quite Frank but here's the
thing there are dozens well at least a
dozen um House Republicans that
represent districts that Joe Biden won
in 2020 and his lik to win in 2024
Democrats are actually counting on this
um and the Republicans don't seem to
understand that those Republicans in
those districts want to win they want to
be remain members of Congress would
those also be the same Republican
senators and representatives who have
taken credit for certain Acts or bills
or
uh monal yeah infrastruct
inflation reduction it's crazy you know
these Republicans who voted no probably
the same people who voted no for veteran
families and the fund for
911 I would assume that those are the
same people now taking credit for those
very things that they said were super
woke socialism this that whatever and
now they show up to their constituents
and they go here's this big check and
this big check was because of me you
know I used to do a a series called
thanks Brandon thanks Brandon I should
bring that back let's listen to this
again because I think it's important for
you to catch the projection here too
listen to the projection from the pety
yeti listen uh it's simple it doesn't
hurt them at all they're doing a great
job for their districts it's not a
political impeachment inquir oh it's not
an political impeachment inquiry that's
exactly what it is she's projecting
she's telling you exactly what it is no
no no we're not inquiring into this you
know what so funny they're like you know
what you know what this political
process that happens inside Congress
which is a political body that is that
is elected to political office uh is
putting an impeachment inquiry but it's
totally not political we're totally not
doing what we are lying about what
they're doing to Donald Trump there a
totally thing we're not doing Texas and
we also don't have any evidence but
we're not going to say that we don't
have any evidence that's true that's
true Texas Paul what do you make of the
petty Yeti here projecting their
political their political a Witch Hunt
uh well she's still butt hurt because
you know they made her the promise that
she would be the one announcing all the
impeachments and [__] like that and then
they yanked that away when she called
little Bobo a little [__] on the floor
they took all her rights and privileges
away so now she's trying to be really
well behaved and you know just stay
right on the whole spin cycle and then
this just is this isn't political we're
just trying to impeach a guy with no
evidence I mean what's political about
that I mean oh Jesus Christ before Gabe
goes I have a great clip here from his
favorite Senator no I'm gon I'm gonna
play this I I started digging into this
situation it's pretty
wild this clip here I don't even know
what this clip's about I just know it's
your favorite Senator it's a nice clip
here we go Mr Senator John kityy I'm
gonna read some words out of this
children's book be real
ass okay let's let's listen to John
Kennedy about free speech and book bands
if he knows anything about free speech
he definitely knows about burning books
I mean Banning books excuse me let's
listen I say I say
boy let's listen to sen gab's favorite
Senator John Kennedy called gender queer
okay let me read an excerpt from that
quote I got a new strap strap on harness
today I can't wait to put it on it will
fit my favorite dildo perfectly you're
going to look so hot I can't wait to
have your [__] in my
mouth I'm going to give you the [__]
of your life then I want you inside of
me
in oh John
Kennedy baby I can't tell you how happy
I am oh my God there come here boy oh my
God what in the [__] just happened yes
well you see you see what happened here
was I was reading from a favorite book
called gender CER and I just had some
recite some of my favorite passages
about strapping on a dildo and taking in
the bud um you it's this is beyond
parody why in the [__] is this not audio
all over the internet right now oh no
believe me I'm going to I'm going to
take this audio because there was
never let's just say maybe I'll receive
a phone call from John Kennedy at some
point leaving me a voic mail about
something he wants me to do to him oh my
god oh my god well here's the thing is I
know we I want to talk about impeachment
but why in the hell why in the hell
didn't I do two hours on this clip alone
oh yeah what the hell is he talking
about Texas PA I know you're going to
get in trouble with Mrs Paul over there
talking about dildos and stons but what
are we going to do the United States is
talking about sticking stuff in their
mouth I don't know John Kennedy seems to
like these passages he seems to have
read them several times before he
recited it uh in the senate committee
man he has a very different Library than
I do I mean mine is right behind me
here you will not find those passages in
my
library but I swear to God I would wait
I was waiting for him to just break out
and say you know oh beler come here boy
I have some something to show you I have
made a
purchase
Oh there's a whole thread here I don't
the whole thread don't know if this
keeps going how long it keeps going it
not only keeps going with him but then
it brings in the witnesses and the
people that are there to speak does it
keep coming and coming and coming I'm
gonna come
coming okay let's let's watch John what
the [__] is with pardon my expression
but what the [__] is with this book He's
reading I mean you know what is the
story behind this I mean this is just
he's he's trying to say that this is a
book that is in a children's library and
it is it in a children is it in this is
like that time when you and I were on
that one uh Twitter space yeah and they
said they were like well we don't want
to ban stuff we just want to remove not
have right remove it we're like that's
Banning let's listen let's listen to
some more John Kennedy uh reading his
favorite book Let's listen uh put some
lube on and got him on his
knees and I began to slide into him from
behind I put some lube on and got him on
his
knees and I began to slide into him from
behind look at their look at the looks
on their face what the [__] who tricked
him into saying this [__] out loud I
don't know one of the AIDS or interns
were like hey you got to this will
totally own the libs and we won't have a
recording in video or audio of you
saying these things here we go I got a
new strap strap on harness
today I can't wait to put it on
you oh Senator John Kennedy you are my
favorite
[__] Senator ever please do not stop
doing this here is a witness um here's a
witness response to that before we let
Gabe go let's let's watch Senator the
words you spoke are disturbing
especially coming out of your mouth is
very disturbing but
I oh I think they're great what are you
talking about [__] this is the
best content that the internet can
deliver us uh on this Tuesday September
12th and today Tuesday September 12th is
the first the very first edition of Gabe
Sanchez what was that live don't forget
as soon as this show is over watch Gabe
here on YouTube or on Twitch if you're
on Facebook you're GNA want to get over
to YouTube and you're going to want to
go to Twitch and you're G to want to
watch what was that live with the guy
with the last name Sanchez Gabe thanks
for joining us we're gonna wrap it up
here with Texas Paul get the hell out of
here and go do your show get the hell
out of here Texas
Paul what an ending there with um
Senator John Kennedy talking about all
his um toys that he um what the [__] was
that yeah you know I just had to just
just Google that real quick because you
know I'll be honest with you I am not
familiar with the book gender queer and
the first headline that pops up is the
Nea didn't recommend the gender queer
book and the other one is uh this is not
in school libraries
and as you keep scrolling down this is
[__] that they just made made
up and you know Senator fog horn Leghorn
just sat on the floor of the Senate and
read porn basically for no freaking
reason I mean literally no reason
because it doesn't fit any of his listen
listen there is a reason that he read
this porn and it is for our internet
entertain this is what the internet is
for folks it's not what the Senate is
for and it shouldn't be what that seat
in the Senate is for that's what rep
publicans clowns use this for is for
their lies and he walked straight into
the internet into his lies so good luck
to John Kennedy and good luck to Gabe
Sanchez on his very first episode and
Texas Paul good luck to you tomorrow I
think I think I'm gonna join you
tomorrow morning right am I is that
right yeah I'm gonna be joining you
tomorrow morning uh so here's the thing
just go to real texas.com go to real
texas.com he's got a show before mine on
Wednesdays I'll join him tomorrow for
just a bit I'll pop in and give Texas
Paul the Tony Michaels treatment on his
show um so I I appreciate you having me
on and Texas Paul I'm glad you're here
today I'm glad we could sort out not
only not only what feckless things that
Kevin McCarthy is doing and what trouble
he's gonna have uh pretending to impeach
Joe Biden but I'm so glad that we could
get to what John Kennedy's favorite book
actually is that hurt man that that
scarred me dude that was just it I
that actually sent me to the internet to
look up that yeah no the Nea did not
recommend this book this is not in
school
libraries you might you know Texas Paul
I don't like to do recommendations or um
you know like um you know but you should
do a video on this you should definitely
do a video on what John Kennedy just
said I think you should no I
mean maybe maybe a tutorial maybe I
don't know I'm just saying I'm just
saying if you want a tutorial for Texas
Paul put it in the comments below and
definitely show up tomorrow for a show
we're gonna be my thing is yeah my thing
is you do you boo boo you know the other
but I don't I don't read I don't read
straight sex I don't read gay sex I
don't read really no no no I am not
doing any of that on my show dude you're
you're missing you're missing out Texas
Paul you're missing out don't miss Texas
Paul though don't miss that on him
tomorrow real Texas paul.com the link is
down below real texas.com thanks for
joining me sir and you thanks yeah go
ahead when when do you want to pop in so
folks know for you know you know when
whenever is good for you when when is a
good time for you tomorrow for me the
show starts at 10:00 I'll send you a
link before the show you pop in when you
want to we'll make it happen great I'll
make sure I'm not naked and I'm clothed
and ready to go and I definitely don't
have my John Kennedy toys on um ready to
do that thing I'll have all that done
before the show and might pop in maybe
like quarter after or something Texas
Paul tomorrow real Texas paul.com you
know this show is going to be on same
time same place don't go anywhere Gabe
Sanchez what was that live is on right
after this surf up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking